you would on the same generation why are
you 47 I am
yeah me too Wow we're the same age
that's crazy is it
yeah because I'll tell you what it is
because the house I watch I was watching
an IBM commercial you and I both dating
in the bank one yeah we talked about
this yeah yeah and I saw another one IBM
I did with Joe Pitka that was actually
play your commercial real over and over
and make her watch it he was making the
kids watch Oh watch this see Bobby's
famous West Covina mall walk around the
mall you know to get noticed
yeah that's good court I love that yeah
I lean against the wall no some people
go hey some people think I'm from
something else like doc do you ever get
recognized for somebody somebody else
no you've never had a are you know
people have seen movies that they
thought I was in and then I inevitably
want to go like google that movie but
people put me as I look now in a movie
in the 80s and I'm like how stupid are
you like you happy do you see what I'm
saying yeah they think hey were you in
such-and-such and then you go look at
that movie and it's like yeah yeah I
would have been 13 then right yeah but
no nobody I mean nobody ever thinks I'm
you know what I'm Tyler just witnessed
it if I knew Tyga and I can tell what I
can I guess what it is it's nothing that
you're struck again no it's my name
people get my name really confidently
wrong so they'll come up to me and be
like hey oh my god Eric Street stone I
love ya but the best one ever the the
the by far the best is I was in New York
City it was one right when the modern
family started to become popular and
this guy picks me up at the hotel he
goes what time's your flight I said it's
six o'clock or whatever those you're not
gonna make that flight do I have
permission to get you to JFK sir I said
of course and he goes so we take off
were bobbing and weaving through Queens
I mean it is an amazing ride I'm in the
back of a mercedes-benz station wagon
you know car car and we're bobbing and
weaving going through traffic honking
the horn and he pulls up screeches two
tires in front of JetBlue and he turns
around amigos miss
the streets tone you have arrived at JFK
like he did you track them oh oh yeah I
was pulling on the lot one time I was
shooting something that I had to go you
know I was going on the same lot every
day dealing with the same security girl
every day and finally she stopped making
me like give her my ID she recognized me
when I pulled up and this on this day
she goes Sarek back street right and I'm
like yeah she would you but if you were
at the airport's I'm strange I never
correct people I use them now as a badge
of I got Erik sandstorm in in London
girl friend was like did he just call
you it's really fun I get Tommy Lee are
you Tommy Lee I do I look like a [ __ ]
drummer from heavy metal bit and they
and then I'll go no they go are you sure
I couldn't no I'm not him Tommy Lee oh
yeah and then when I go Bobby that's my
name Bobby Lee and they go oh yeah well
whatever like they're you know they'll
do they'll take it anyway I thought you
were gonna say people always confuse me
and they say are you Bobby Lim
you know because like that's another
Asian sounding oh yeah that yeah yeah oh
yeah do I get the lead portion right
yeah wrong I mean anyway is there um
when you get recognizers are there
things something things that like
irritate you that ii like that you have
borders i have borders i don't like to
be touched and grabbed what about if
you're in the middle of a meal I'm in
the middle of a meal depending on what
I'm talking about it's more about like
the conversation that's happening
because I feel it's my obligation to my
friends and family to be present with
them when I'm with them and having like
meaningful conversations because I'm I'm
not always with them so that when a
person that I don't know comes up and
wants to have a moment of my time I
don't have a problem with giving them a
moment of my time but not necessarily if
my best friend says his wife was just
diagnosed with say cancer yeah I got it
like stay focus isin yeah my life
in their life so I will tell people I
would be happy to like talk to him in
just a minute and
usually people are like super cool about
that and then on other times they turn
on you very quickly will [ __ ] you I'm
never watching your show again oh really
no yeah really of course yeah and you
know because I've always been cursed a
little bit with my physicality that I
can't really say things to people that
don't come off as though I might be
starting [ __ ] with them you know what I
mean yeah like I can't say you know hey
yeah I'd love to talk to you in just a
minute you know and I'm trying to keep a
smile that's just not how it comes off
I've always gotten myself in trouble in
situations with my face ah what I'm
annoyed people know I'm annoyed and I
can't necessarily bury that yeah but no
I don't ever I mean its fizz it's the
physical stuff if people grab my elbow
and like say hey come over here meet my
so-and-so or whatever I'm like don't
don't grab me though do people pick me
up from behind that's so cute
no people will just like white dudes
like six foot eight and they'll do the
accent - Asian accent oh the army story
right that hard yeah I'm just like a
marionette and but you know karate
someone have a white belt with a stripe
yeah not much but you know I also don't
like what when they don't know that cuz
I come you know how I come across mean
but in a funny way yeah
sarcastic right so I mean I made fun of
your hair the andre agassi but that's
because I love you you puffy Trent you
don't really have puffy Chinese that I
was just doing that you know to have fun
huh but if you don't know that about me
right then they get offended quickly
like some guy couldn't take a photo
what's up [ __ ] boy yeah and they'll go
what'd you call me
oh that's how I talk yeah I'm sorry that
makes me sad for you because anybody
that knows you knows that that's just
who that's who you are yeah yeah yeah
and they should be excited that you're
giving them an authentic moment right of
with you
yeah what I would say about that and
that's that's sort of how I am as far as
I really pride myself and you can ask ty
because he's with me a lot of the times
where it's like I give people exactly
what they give me if they're super cool
with me and super fun then that's
exactly what I am yeah if you're rude
with me like in like why your your
you're not as fat as you are on TV like
people have said stuff like oh you're
way more handsome in person or people
that like to come up to you and tell you
that they don't watch your TV show like
people really enjoy doing that yeah come
up and be like my wife watches a show I
don't Whitney hey she mentioned it on
this podcast to were like oh yeah cuz a
guy can't admit to liking her comedy
they they're always like yeah I don't
know who you are but my girlfriend likes
you so can I get a picture
ya know what that happens when somebody
says like you know I my friend just took
a photo I don't know who you are but I
might as well get one too I always say
no yeah no yeah I do say no I big like
the words like no because you what what
what what why I guess well you're not a
fan Yeah right and then you're gonna
Google me later and then they're gonna
put like here's the guy you know the fat
guy from Goonies I don't know how they
do it yeah I mean yeah I had a guy one
time I forget who I was with but I also
have to yield to whoever I'm with
because I don't ever mind really taking
pictures but if you're with somebody
that doesn't want to then you're like
[Music]
yeah yeah like whatever but I was with
somebody and they they were like can I
take a picture and the guy was like no
can we can we catch one afterwards he's
like whoa the picture already would have
been done by now if you would have just
said yes oh my god but 99.999% of my
interactions are all good and cool and
fun and stuff I enjoy it because you
have a great foundation yeah but I also
like I do believe what you said which is
that I haven't changed and I didn't like
people grabbed my elbow before I was on
TV and I don't like it now it's no
different it doesn't have anything to do
with I think that I'm better than
someone or a fan or something it's just
like don't touch me like I don't want to
touch you you don't touch me yeah yes I
like people touching this area yeah the
face is there
face is a big no-no but a lot of people
do that just randomly like noogie ya
know I have people like dudes grab my
[ __ ] from behind just like with our
middle right with their middle right
they figured no they don't finger from
me but just on the pants let's see this
is my butthole and they'll just put this
in my bathroom and in India and go
what's my shits being squished like that
you know in my butthole then are you
conflicted at that time
are you like well yeah I'm like what you
doing I'll say it
[Music]